For each of these equations, m is just the coefficient in front of the term with
an x to the first. So, in the first equation, y equals 100 plus 50x, m is just
50. There are two little potentially tricky spots here. Since in the second to
the last equation, we have y equals 12 minus 3x, m is equal to negative 3. Since
you will recall that in the form of the equation, the general form, we have y
equals mx and no sign in front of the m, so we need to include the sign as part
of the coefficient. The second potentially tricky thing is for the equation, y
equals 5. We don't have a term here with an x. What that really means, is that
we have the term plus 0x added onto the end of this. Clearly, 0x is just equal
to 0, but writing this let's us see that m, the slope here, is actually equal to
0. This actually makes sense, since y equals 5 is just a horizontal line, whose
slope is 0. Moving onto our values of b, these are just the constant terms on
the right side of each of these equations. Negative signs need to be included as
part of the b term, and then the equation y equals 5x, since we don't explicitly
see a constant term added out here, b must be equal to zero. Having this
information written out explicitly like this, makes writing the equations in y
equals mx plus b form pretty simple. Hopefully, now you feel very confident that
all of these equations can be written in this precise form.